we're headed to a house community house
run by LULAC which is a major Latino
advocacy group in the United States they
have come out really strongly against
Herbalife they believe the company has
been taken advantage of Latinos LULAC
has pulled together some victims one of
them Miguel Calderon he can document as
much as $22,000 of these loss so he's
you know a good example of the kind of
person that though Ackman says is being
taken advantage of hey how are you
Dwayne Stanford with Bloomberg how did
you first learn about Herbalife yokomen
state coordinator there one evil you've
been sick and what was the total amount
that you ended up investing so the more
we talked to these victims the more
became clear they didn't actually read
the contracts that they signed in fact
they really didn't have a good
understanding of the mechanism for which
they would earn the money they thought
they'd earned they thought if you
invested you would double your money one
of the names that kept coming up was
cesar Caballero he was sort of a
godfather of Herbalife in the area these
victims were part of his network he was
their sponsor so we wanted to find him
talk to him and try to get his side of
the story
so this is where Cesar apparently had
one of his nutrition stores there's some
Herbalife powders there in the window
seals so this definitely used to be
something related to Herbalife so we
wanted to talk to Caesar Caballero so we
tracked him down and he met with us at
one of his nutrition clubs my business
is the concentration in co-working of
Miguel called around said he paid as
much as twenty two thousand dollars I
couldn't sell the product is there any
truth to their allegations there so no
tengo el control no tenemos a Houston
derecho empanada dealing
el derecho de rek Lamar pero aquí lo
único que es que si trabajo en el dinero
y no trabajar not a nerdy [ __ ] so would
there ever be a time when you would buy
a large portion of product up front and
then sell in a store or in a nutrition
club no no as I reported it became clear
that what I was seeing in the trenches
mirrored very closely what we were
seeing at the top with this battle
between the hedge fund managers one side
is saying the company is clearly a fraud
a pyramid scheme the other side saying
it's a legitimate business after I left
Chicago
I wanted to delve deeper into the actual
complaints filed with the Attorney
General to see if we could get a handle
on exactly what they spent twenty five
thousand dollars he says he spent and
lost on Herbalife one of the problems I
had with the documents is that they were
heavily redacted and I don't have
subpoena power the people that do or the
FTC even so a former FTC lawyer I spoke
with said it will still be a challenge
to prove its pyramid proving that an
operation is a pyramid can be very
complex
the FTC will be looking at all of the
evidence that gathers to determine
whether the operation is primarily
designed to sell distributorships or is
it really designed to sell product to
ultimate consumers and that can be a
difficult line to draw all of this will
likely take a long time I would suspect
it would be at least a year it could be
even longer did he ever have questions
when he was first going in like how this
sounds too good to be true and he will
see is Herbalife a pyramid scheme
no CM por ciento no